50 years ago in a lightning six-day war
Israel captured East Jerusalem the West
Bank and Gaza the Israelis called it
liberation the Palestinians saw it as
the start of occupation
now conflict zone is in Israel and the
West Bank to record a series of special
interviews marking the last 50 years of
conflict this week my guest here in Tel
Aviv is the former Israeli prime
minister and defense minister err hood
Barack why is the peace process that he
and so many others worked on such a
failure
[Music]
you
[Music]
every barrack welcome to conflict thank
you for having me the Israeli writer a
Moses says that Israelis were condemned
to rule over people who didn't want to
be ruled by you you condemn yourself
television I don't believe we condemned
we they present government and previous
government for 50 years ended up ruling
over and other people and that at least
that the long run should be corrected
and we supposed to do it not just
because of the moral issue of our
neighbors but basically stemming out of
our own and needs a density security and
future yeah but you were warned as Abba
Eban said in 1967 your foreign minister
at the time he coded a barrel of
dynamite and he said we're sitting here
with two populations one of them endowed
with all the civil rights and the other
denied all rights this is a picture of
two classes of citizens that's hard to
defend even in the special context of
Jewish history what he was suggesting
was that it was immoral wasn't it yeah
but the see operation whole occupation
is more than unfair you know the same
Abba Eban said that Israel can never
allow to come back to the borders of 67
which he called out with scalloped
borders I don't believe in either we
shouldn't go to extremism
it's Leawood we are facing a problem we
have a it's a problem of your area isn't
it you know no no no no we will attack
if you get back the land he wouldn't way
they made a decision
it didn't it didn't start it without
taking over this area it was started by
a an attack on Israel or a tie put
around our necks annexed in a way that
compelled us to take action we a kind of
luckily enough we won the 67 world we
defeated three enemies and ended up with
a lot of area so I can bacon Eric a year
of choice a 1982 he said it was a war of
choice let's be honest you attack them
with Israeli here
he made the war of choice in Lebanon 82
by the 67 was it that the issues are the
technical question of who pulled the
trigger first it is who created
situations that compelled Israel out of
survival consideration to fight we
fought we will will never be apologetic
about getting out of getting the news
out of a round out neck
you're not apologetic but isn't it time
to admit that the lives of some 4
million people controlled by a
government which they are not entitled
to elect is immoral and unjust that I do
not start my consideration from the
moral issues I might not be you don't
care about my god I care about morality
but I killed more about our very
survival in life and I should tell you
that I do not disagree with the bottom
line of what you are trying to to kind
of say somehow a view the situation
created in such that Israel faces a
choice if we keep controlling the whole
area from the Mediterranean to River
Jordan well some 13 million people are
living 8 million either in five million
Palestinians death if only one one
entity reigns over this whole area named
Israel it will become inevitably that's
the key world
inevitably eternal Jewish an
undemocratic if they can vote to the
Knesset it is overnight a bi-national
state and within few years by national
states with other majority and permanent
civil war but they are not a moment the
state said you have at the moment is an
apartheid state the other alternative is
that we will it's not yet a powder but
it might will come on this slippery
slope to all the parties neither if the
zombies dream so we have to change it a
we have compelling imperative to do it
for other our own and I see the moral
issue in it but the Arabs initiate the
situation never gave us an opportunity I
propose at Camp David to give other fat
metaphorically metaphorically speaking
nicely plasters and the body I always
get on to Camp David in a little alone
but I just want to stress that Israel
never had any intention of giving back
East Jerusalem to do all all the major
settle block does yeah major said my
book we think should be remained under
our control as part of our secure even
the rest of the world without your
having them as illegal banned an
obstacle it will become legal if and
when the two sides which an agreement
apart upon which a mutually agreed line
will be delineated within which we have
a solid Jewish majority for generations
to come and the Palestinians have enough
playful a vibrant violate a vibrant a
viable Palestinian a demilitarized state
but it's been illegal for 50 years you
want another 50 years before you make it
legal no no I saw the Palestinians
suffer with its illegality that you can
call to me I will repeat it as many
times as you mention it we will never
feel morally apologetic about the root
causes of this situation it will all
compelled upon us by the policies and by
the Richmond Okanagan they spill Arab
maybe which you know we cannot ask him
is in heaven already I don't believe
that he disputed but having said that
I'm still of the position that we have a
compelling imperative stemming out of
our own care about our future and
identity to disengage from the
Palestinians and our government have to
to expect
I've been tried it Ellis tried it even
between his first attempt tried it I've
tried it and failed Camp David being a
head and Yahoo even behemoth help tried
a little bit a almost tried it later
Sean pulled out of Gaza and in all cases
we couldn't find the weddings rightness
of the Palestinians right to make the
tough decisions which are needed on Delp
out with a Vidal people they came by the
tea that we have to make tough decisions
facing out I understand that but you
don't celebrate the occupation do you
don't celebrate 50 years of this
occupation we also you folded a crucial
steak in 2002 you gave an interview to
the New York Review of Books you called
it a crucial mistake occupying the West
Bank and Gaza along with the Sinai and
the Golan Heights you think that Israel
should have given it back straightaway
in 67 bills I know don't take one
sentence for very long interview of my
advice try to - it's pretty cool but you
know nothing that they could've a
crucial they take addition by it's
called off kind of distortion by
addition I don't like it I I'm here you
can ask me so I tell you we did not make
a mistake by removing the tie from
around our neck we didn't say we will
never become apologetic about winning
and surviving but at the same time with
the Jewish people won't hear a Jewish
Democratic sorry state we don't want
neither a bi-national state with a civil
war know apartheid so I'm of the
position which is at least at the bottom
line not very far from we are trying to
describe namely that we have a need to
find a way to disengage from policy
preferably going through the
international regional conference which
is now on the table for several years we
have common interest with the Muslim sue
night leadership facing okay but let us
stay away let's finish with the
settlements is it right to keep the
settlement or wrong do you think you
have a right angle settlement eighty
percent of the settlers are living
within what we call the settlement
blocks which altogether right overall
are however so I define exactly what's
right and what's wrong and it has a
content not that one word answer 88% of
cetera which live within the settlement
blocs
which altogether cover no more the five
six percent of the area of the West Bank
and as well as the Jewish neighborhoods
in eastern Jerusalem they're all
legitimate should remain part of Israel
even in a peace agreement and should
culture it lease walked with other areas
with the Palestinian okay when you say
try to let their only problem is the
isolate itself
some 100 of them the only welcome for
you it's a big problem for the rest of
the world because they don't know I then
made a mistake of our government if that
they cannot differentiate and cannot
explain to the world that you want to
stick to the settlement blocs but have
to make decisions about those perfectly
well what you are doing they just don't
like it they think it's illegal and
against them now the world does not make
any differentiation through the
settlement blocs which are essentially
needed for our secure vault has had sent
in here I think about this and it still
doesn't accept your view of this and no
part of it you know and I was not a
matter of explanation a matter of fact
when I was a Prime Minister we enjoy the
support of the whole world for output
policy because it was clear that on one
hand we are still building in the within
the settlement blocs but we are
genuinely ready to make a deal with the
Palestinians and give up the isolated
Sur knew then isolated settlement does
nothing to do nothing to do with the
security of Israel when you were divided
and blocks extremely book when you were
Prime Minister dr. Barrick you didn't
establish any new settlements but you
certainly expanded the existing laws
didn't you that violated the spirit of
your existing commitments under the Oslo
peace accord did this so on the one hand
you said to the you know Palestinians
let's make peace in a matter of months
on the other you went about expanding
the thing the Palestinians hated most to
settle I told Alfred very clearly it
takes 18 months to build the house in
Israel or in the territories and we have
an opportunity to strike a deal within
less than 18 months so why should you
care if we agree on a line that will be
the border between our two states and
then you a new buildings that are now
just being a bit will end up being on
the other side gets affected but he did
it but he did say you said why should
you get heated can you didn't see it
ever from his point of view
I never load it from here better better
than any other individual and children
probably since then I tried to see the
Palestinian point of view as well and
take it into account that you talk into
account years of humiliating occupation
years of your check site I use of
Israeli guy Internet I go in count
everything I was born long enough ago to
see the emergence of the State of Israel
we were hardly been announced or five
Arab armies attacked us and try to kill
the baby because before we can stand on
its feet and we survived
we will not be apologetic about it and
you should love it or hate it but that's
the reality especially long ago hating
it the rest of the world thinks that
your settlement and your occupation is
illegal and I only the right-wing here I
dress that takes it league no I seek the
belt I know I think the most of the
people the world will fully understand
if Israeli government was clever enough
to make the differentiation during the
settlement blocks which are needed for
our security we're ready to compensate
with other relatives about at least
partially and the isolated segments the
isolated settlements is the place well a
we agree that they are an obstacle on
the way to peace rather than part of it
okay
looking at that Camp David summit which
was supposed to be a make-or-break deal
at the end of it in the year 2000
President Clinton you and the other
Arafat at Camp David
it failed didn't it it was badly
prepared you didn't come with any great
expectations they didn't come with any
great expectations it was wrong I got a
whole wine what do you mean but fail
it's clearly that he didn't achieve
breakout a breakthrough will you blame
them for the failure you arranged the
loss of course I but the causal chain is
not there it is not the failing to
achieve an agreement cause the Intifada
it's the other way around we were
heading toward a
a collusion inevitable explosion I tried
my best to avoid it by being ready to
give a generous proposal in order to
avoid it if it's possible but I didn't
trust you I compared it now or no reason
for Ghana to trust me and always after
the issue your expansion of the
settlement say no it doesn't how we
cannot and should not get any
recognition especially not on mr.
allopath but we are ready to go very far
it if he were ready to consider our
proposal you said that you had no
Palestinian partner for peace no I said
it afterwards I said we brother heaven
but that's how I said that we do not
have a partner in other fad for the
present time and it was accurate
description of the situation but the
Palestinians had engaged over and over
again in peace talks in 93 when they
signed the threadbare Oslo agreement in
94 with the Gaza Jericho green in 95
with the interim agreement on the West
Bank and Gaza Strip 2008 they even came
back in 2001 do Yama they were engaging
with you well engaging and engaging is
always a party of two you know it said
they were engaged by the navel and the
outfit were ready to take the decisions
I took painful decision on behalf of
ourselves of course conditional on the
possibility the other part will take the
the counter kind of party a decision on
the Palestinian behalf which he never
did he we headed a treat I compared it
to a fire erupted in a cottage of two
families the two owners are running from
both sides to put down the fire
one of them even carried the great both
of the best firefighter one else but you
don't know if he's at the pyramid with
the fuel and the matches in his pocket
you had a big round with cleanser at the
summit didn't you you had a big round if
you relate he says you reneged on a
commitment to transfer three Jerusalem
villages to the Palestinians and he was
furious he said it was the first time he
made out to be a false path basically
Clinton was very positive energy alcohol
position and he but you are around his
great virtue was that he was trusted by
the other side as well but the Aventa to
describe happened several months before
the the actual Camp David summit in
Jerusalem we committed ourselves but at
the moment the day's the day that we
have to positive definite I will stand
against the whole Knesset fighting for
passing this in a parliamentary vote
it ended after the same day under a
silence kind of waiver of Alif at the
Palestinian security forces opened fire
with the weapons we provided them on
Israeli soldier I told a both Clinton
and Aleph at under this times I do not
negotiate if you use the weapons that we
gave you to keep security and order
within the Palestinian against the
Israeli soldier that mr. MacMurray the
Israeli historian of each lines has the
most fundamental course at the breakdown
in July 2008 Camp David was Israel's
violation of the spirit of Oslo and he
said there's something deeply dishonest
in the Israeli position israel's
rhetoric was the rhetoric of peace but
its actions revealed it's hidden agenda
which was territorial expansion at the
expense of the palestinians but i'm not
true isn't it it's not not just in no
time at all you know you ever hear
actually say it's actually I played the
game didn't he of appearing to give
concessions but I always have no
concessionary no concession is under
subsidy we cannot now dive into the
strategy of it such a me really passed
away many years ago and he said Allison
you know you were Yahoo okay let me
repeat there was no trust I repeat the
the argument against this notion by
addition you took a quotation for one
historian not the most respected a one a
revisionist one that a majority for 90%
of
other historians describe the same issue
in a different way so it's a matter of
your choice but I don't highly respect
the history version of the historian you
mentioned when you went to war mr. bat
when he went to war with the
Palestinians and you did in 2008-2009
Operation Cast Lead in Gaza do you think
it was a fair fight I know what is fair
in no country under earth log of Ehrman
in its full senses can I say accept the
reality that one-celled of its
population should be in shelters within
15 to 45 seconds as a way of life
threatened by terrorists or shooting of
it
McHugh every largest must all take a war
within the world wrong within civilian
occupation deliberately you know our
usual aircraft I don't
armoured personnel carriers but we
rarely copter we are they didn't have
any of them will limit laser-guided bomb
we're a little we are limited by our own
norms and we put limits on yourself on
the use of weapons against a terrorist
which are deliberately deployed
themselves within a civilian population
shooting from former schools and former
from within habitated
areas you put less but by the time your
Operation Cast Lead was finished
according to international agencies
including the World Health Organization
they reported that 14 percent of the
buildings in Gaza were partially or
completely destroyed 700 factories and
businesses partially or completely
destroyed 16 hospitals 38 primary health
care centers 280 schools 250 wells
massing of these this was proportional I
think of this they could or should have
happened if the Palestinians or the
Hamas a will focused on building the
Gaza Strip is why they were able to
respond in rocket attacks it hardly did
any damage
vut ability you know I once brought
hosted the President Obama when he was
still a candidate in today or that City
just behind the fence in Gaza and we
showed him the way that kindergartens
are run in shelters or the the remnants
of the rocket shot and asked him if this
was an American city and your daughters
were in this kindergarten that was their
age at the time would you accept it he
his answer was I would take any any
considering step to put an end to it and
that's exactly what we will do in
Operation Cast Lead thirteen Israelis
died four of them from friendly fire
only nine and Amnesty International
calculated that fourteen hundred gardens
were killed including three hundred
children look at the victim at the bath
who was the perfect I mean I'm not I
know everything I know P or then I'm not
happy with any human life he didn't he
was to avoid it three hundred Alton I'm
not happy I'm very sorry for it but I
cannot tell you that I would not repeat
it if the life and security of our own
people is at stake but you have a token
of punitive attacks and you a new a
punitive attacks which was inside the
Israeli Defense Forces major-general
Guardi isin court spoke in 2008 about
the tremendous damage Israel had
inflicted two years earlier in Beirut in
the DA he had murder and he said what
happened in dahi in 2006 will happen in
every village from which shots are fired
on Israel we will use disproportionate
force against it and we will cause
immense damage and destruction and
that's what you set out to do in
Operation Cast Lead to be
disproportionate and caused immense
damage and destruction didn't know those
damage but it never was aimed at the
civilian population it was aimed at the
bankers or 16 Hospital primary health
care centers
lady schools 250 well 300,000 trees are
not a zone noting that the alien
population was not in the distribution
camel period never ended civilian
population this problem the challenge
you might find in other places as well
but in Israel it's very kind of
sharpened by the situation they the
toast are now deliberately operating
form within these places within schools
within the medical station so on and
with the most accurate even with the
most accurate weapons you cannot avoid
certain collateral damage I propose to
you to look at the collateral damage
that is called by Americans when they
acting in Afghanistan or Pakistan or by
the British when they acted in in
Baghdad or in other places or in Basra
and you will find the deaths unfortunate
part of the super image of war it's very
what good have all these expensive
weapons done you you haven't really in
Israel had a night of peace in 50 years
now when you keep on doing the same
things and the same failed policies that
we we have we have we had many quiet
nights in Israel the last 50 years last
few years I always say surprise when we
we talk to the cameras to public's they
seeked in Tel Aviv you probably cross
the street by running in zigzags with
the video profile don't we the army
roads at night Allah Tala Stinney ins in
the West Bank Noah and the screaming
children and the old hope of working up
at night when your army goes in I don't
I don't love I see everything
believe me see everything I work with
our advanced units at almost any place
they well and I know exactly I do not
describe it as a paradise it's a tough
for both sides and tougher on the
Palestinian ISM on our soldiers but
that's the consequences of situation and
I am confident that we have to change it
it's responsibility of leaders on both
sides to change it but that will not
bring me to be apologetic about our
focus
unprotected the life of our own people
and their security while twined we I
always compare it to situation where you
have to hold your pointing finger close
to the trigger ready to pull it but the
other hand the left hand usually look
for any door window or opening into
another period of agreement conciliation
and peace all right every bar could have
your complexion and thank you very much
indeed thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]